Speaker of the House Nancy Pelosi tells
President Trump not to give the State of
the Union address on the heels of the
Steve King debacle Democrats tried to
claim that all Republicans are racist
and another razor company goes after men
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show
[Music]
well we have a lot coming up here today
I'm a venture peer I'm obviously with it
today I'm Ben Shapiro it's the day after
my birthday guys you're gonna have to
give me a little room to run and I do
appreciate all of the nice birthday
wishes from yesterday especially you on
the left who sent me private messages
wishing me a happy birthday but would
not do so publicly for fear of being
called out by our leftist friends for
treating me as a human really appreciate
that that was great we're gonna get to
all the news whoo a lot of news coming
up here today I also want to remind you
that I'm speaking at the March for Life
on Friday which should be a blast doing
my podcast live from there we have some
special guest surprises if we can make
it work at the March for Life so be sure
to show up for that first before we get
to any of the news you need to look good
okay you look like a slob I'm just I
started break it to you but you do
because you need a better suit okay
dudes if you want to look cool you want
to look snazzy you want to look like you
have a tailored suit you ought to have a
tailored suit a suit made for you and
that's where endo Chino comes in Indo
Chino is fantastic they have a huge
variety of fabrics colors and patterns
and it makes them incredibly stylish and
its unique experience you play designer
you get to pick all of the details on
your so you get to pick the fabric you
get to pick the interior interior lining
of the suit you get to pick a monogram
you get to pick will appelles all of it
Indo Chino is North America's leading
made-to-measure menswear company they
make suits in shirts to your exact
measurements for an unparalleled fit and
comfort dudes love the wide selection of
high quality fabrics and colors to
choose from and the option to
personalize all of those details here's
how it works you visit a showroom and
have them take your measurements
personally or measure at home yourself
and shop online and Indo Chino comm
choose your fabric inside and now choose
your design customizations submit your
measurements with your choices and then
relax well your suit gets professionally
tailored and then mailed to you in a
couple of weeks this week my listeners
can get any premium Indo Chino suit for
just 359 bucks at Indo Chino comm when
you enter promo code
Shapiro's at checkout that is 50% off
the regular price for a made-to-measure
premium suit plus shipping is free that
is Indo Chino com promo code Shapiro for
any premium suit for just 300 59 bucks
free shipping incredible deal for a
premium made-to-measure suits go track
them out right now Indo Chino my
favorite suit is an Indo Chino suit it's
like a glove it's great go check them
out Indo Chino calm and when you use
promo code Shapiro you get eddie suit
for a 359 bucks which is lower than you
get at a department store alrighty so we
begin today with Speaker of the House
Nancy Pelosi who has now decided that
the president
not give the State of the Union address
from Congress now let me just say this
if President Trump is responsible for
the death of the State of the Union
address it will be the greatest
achievement in the last 100 years of the
presidency I cannot express how much I
despise the State of the Union address
in fact about five years ago when my
daughter was born she was born the day
of the State of the Union address I was
grateful for two things that day one
that my daughter was born two that her
birth had obviated the need for me to
cover the State of the Union address in
fact I tweeted that out on the day of
her birth I suited out thank you to my
daughter for being born on the day of
the State of the Union address so I
don't have to cover this bleep show I
hate the State of the Union address it
is an anti Republican anti-democratic
minar kacal spectacle of nonsense where
the president shows up and all the
legislators cheer and they clap and they
pretend that they like the president and
then everybody smiles is that the
president is the king and he's arrived
for a royal visit I hate the State of
the Union no matter who the president is
so if Donald Trump just issues a long
letter the way that George Washington
did for his original State of the Union
address he just sends a letter to
Congress and then maybe he does an oval
office address summing up the main
points in like seven minutes that would
be great I would be so happy with the
president I cannot even tell you well
Nancy Pelosi wants the president not to
show up in Congress now the real reason
Nancy Pelosi doesn't want the president
to show up is because he will then have
a captive audience for legitimately a
hundred million people and he will tell
them that the reason the government
shutdown is still on is because the
Democrats refused to reopen the
government that's really what they are
upset about Nancy Pelosi wrote a letter
to trump today and here is what the
letter said she said dear mr. president
on January 3rd it was my privilege as
Speaker to invite you to deliver the
State of the Union address on January
29th the Constitution calls for the
president to from time to time give to
Congress information of the State of the
Union notice by the way that the
constitutional language never never
suggested that the president has to show
up in Congress and then jabbered us for
an hour which is what the State of the
Union is during the 19th century and up
until the presidency of Woodrow Wilson
these annual State of the Union messages
were delivered to Congress in writing
and since the start of the modern
budgeting in fiscal year 1977 a State of
the Union address has never been
delivered during a government shutdown
in September 2018 secretary Nilsen
designated the State of the Union
addresses as national special security
events
recognising the need for the full
resources of the federal government to
be brought to bear to ensure the
security of these events the
extraordinary demands presented by NS
SES required weeks of detailed planning
with dozens of agencies working together
to prepare for the safety of all
participants the US Secret Service was
designated as the lead federal agency
responsible for coordinating planning
exercising and implementing security for
national special security events by
public law 106 5 4 for December 19th
2000 however both the u.s. Secret
Service and the Department of Homeland
Security have not been funded for 26
days now
with critical departments hamstrung by
furloughs sadly given the security
concerns in am US government reopens
this week I suggest that we work
together to determine another suitable
date after government has reopened for
this address or for you to consider
delivering your State of the Union
address in writing to Congress on
January 29th thank you for your
attention in this matter so that's not
actually Pelosi asking Trump not to do
the State of the Union that's we're
saying we're not doing the State of the
Union that that is her basically saying
straight out I am uninviting you you're
not welcome to show up in Congress now
Trump has a couple of options one Trump
could go to Senate Majority Leader
McConnell and say listen we're just
gonna do the State of the Union from the
Senate floor right we'll just go over to
the Senate it'll be smaller most of the
Democrats aren't gonna show up anyway
and then I'll give the State of the
Union address from there or
alternatively Trump could say look
another stupid pump is spectacle that
I've ended so great I'm all for this
this is fantastic and I'll give a little
speech that'll take ten minutes and not
waste everybody's time and it'll be
complete with visuals and spectacle
that's what he should do all right the
president should do is he should just
give another oval office address except
this time I've never understood why
president's done to this legitimately
like we have this tool it's this thing
it's called television and on television
you can show images and when you show
images on television they have more
emotional impacts than just a face
talking at you which is why if you
listen to the show you should buy a
subscription so you can actually see
when we show the clips and watch as I
make faces at those clips and when we
actually show information it is more
telling than when we do not the
president has so many opportunities to
do something unique with the State of
the Union specifically because Nancy
Pelosi is doing this and save us so much
time and effort in the process and get
rid of the monarchic spectacle so again
if President Trump decides not to give
the State of the Union I
be so happy with him I cannot even say
it'll just be another benefit of the
government shutdown everybody's very
concerned about all the cost of the
government shutdown and yes the
government shutdown has costs but this
would be a real benefit us not having to
sit there for two hours and do the the
runway show for the for the President of
the United States and members of
Congress and pretend that we all like
them and and then we have the president
who just shout out to people up in the
balcony and here's Bob and Bob had a
hard life story and everybody cheers for
Bob and then we all sit down and we
stand up and sit down again if we could
do not that this year oh man that'd be
great maybe the president should just
instead of the State of the Union
address he should sit in the Oval Office
and he should just rebroadcast like a
football game and the ratings would be
amazing and people would love it
maybe he should actually like broadcast
a Wrestlemania spectacle where he has
somebody dress up with the head of CNN
it would be like so many different
options available and I'm very excited
about all of them
in the end Trump will give a State of
the Union address I'll probably do it
from Congress and I'll be very irritated
but for the moment I choose to remain
optimistic about all this well that was
actually the second most interesting
story of the day the most interesting
story of the day was Alexander Oh Cosmo
course again the reason I talk about her
is because she is now an important
person as deemed by the media and also
because she says such dumb things on a
regular basis so this is fantastic
so she did an interview with The
Washington Post and she was asked about
conservative media setting her up as
another bogeyman on the left and here is
what she said is she said this interview
was given about a week and a half ago
she said I also think it's encouraging
because this is my sixth day in Congress
and they're out there out of all their
artillery the nude because there's a
fake nude that was put up of her and the
Daily Caller covered it so the nude the
nude is supposed to be like the bazooka
you know like we're gonna take her down
dude you're all out of bullets you're
all out of bombs you're all out of all
of this stuff what have you got left I'm
six days into the term and you already
used all your ammo so enjoy being
exhausted for the next two years while
we run trained on the progressive agenda
now that's not a great phrase run
trained on the progressive agenda for
those of you who are innocents in the
world for those of you who are not
familiar
the urban dictionary for those of you
who may be Tony or upper-class and you
have no idea what the phrase run train
means it means a bunch of men having
gang sex with a woman that's what that's
what running train means okay running
train it is a term of awful import it is
just it's a terrible term and usually
it's used in derogatory fashion like if
you wanted to mean somebody and what's
amazing about this it's she's Alex from
the Bronx right she ain't upper-class
she's she's down-home
you know what the people with the
talents folk is she as she said in a
recent we put the talents people in the
bogs she said she's gonna run train on
the progressive agenda would the
headlines have ever stopped if Sarah
Palin had said that in 2009 then wow
look how dumb Sarah Palin is look how
stupid she is for saying that very weird
that Alexander Ocasio Cortes wants to
gang rape the progressive agenda and it
seems like a weird thing to do who she's
a progressive maybe that should be
present in from 2020 slogan running
train on the agenda don't worry she is
the the best in the brightest among us
she's not she's not dumb in any way
knows it she's real smart I know because
I've been told so by it by so many
members of the media okay the big story
of the day overall
is not any of is not any of that and
it's actually that there was a a major
terrorist attack in Syria on a much more
serious topic obviously the Washington
Post reports the Islamic state asserted
responsibility Wednesday for a suicide
blast in the u.s. patrolled city of maan
base in Syria the first such attack
since President Trump said American
forces would withdraw from the country
because the militant group has been
largely defeated a spokesman for the
us-led coalition battling Isis said the
US service members were killed while
conducting a routine patrol in the city
but did not say how many died or provide
further details some reports were
suggesting by the way that these US
soldiers were killed at a restaurant in
a suicide bombing so the the height of
cowardice by members of Isis something
we've come to expect in Washington US
officials said initial reports suggested
that four Americans may have died
earlier Reuters news agency quoted an
unidentified US official as saying four
soldiers were killed and three wounded
in the blast there was no immediate
confirmation of those figures from
operation inherent resolve which is the
us-led coalition against Isis statements
published by Isis's official news agency
amok said that the attacker used an
explosive
of late invested target coalition forces
the amok statement claimed nine American
troops were killed or injured in the
attacks but didn't present evidence for
the claim
the britain-based Syrian Observatory for
Human Rights said at least 19 people
when wounds in her killed the Kurdish
news agency said at least 10 people were
injured in the attack which it said
occurred outside a popular restaurant
and what this has to do with President
Trump withdrawing from Syria open
question open question because Isis
obviously would pursuit pursuing
violence in any case but it is not
uncommon for terrorist groups to ramp up
violence right in the immediate in the
immediate for running to a troop
withdrawal specifically so that they can
then claim to their supporters that they
drove the United States out of Syria
that Isis drove the United States out of
the area so they unleash a wave of
bombings right as the United States is
about to pull out anyway I wanna get
into a little bit more of that and then
I want to talk to you about Chris
Christie who has a new book coming out
and I also want to talk to you about
Steve King's there's a lot more of the
left focusing on Steve King first got to
talk to you about how you are going to
make your business better this year so
you're figuring out how to make your
business better this year which roles to
fill with different people and you need
a great way to find employees well the
best way to do it is zipper crews calm /
daily wire it is smart it's the smart
thing to do
zip recruiter finds qualified candidates
for you you have powerful matching
technology that scans thousands of
resumes so identify people with the
right skills education and experience
and then actively invite them to apply
to your job so you get qualified
candidates fast
that's why zip recruiter is rated number
one by employers in the United States
that rating comes from hiring sites on
trust pilot with over a thousand reviews
and right now my listeners can try zip
recruiter for free at zip recruiter comm
slash daily wire there's a reason we use
zip recruiter here at the daily wire
offices if you love the show show your
support for the show and zip recruiter
by going to zip recruiter comm slash
daily wire again that is zip recruiter
comm slash daily Wire super cooter is
indeed the smartest way to hire go check
them out one more time at zip recruiter
comm slash daily wire they can try zip
recruiter for free when you use that
slash daily wire zip recruiter comm
slash a daily wire and make sure that
you have it the best employees possible
ok meanwhile Chris Christie has a new
book coming out and the media are all
agog at it because this is how it works
anybody who was once close with Trump
becomes an interesting person to the
media as soon as they turn
on Trump now the last thing I want to
hear is Chris Christie whining about why
Trump was mean to him chris Christie is
probably responsible for Trump being
present in some ways and Chris Christie
committed the first political
murder-suicide on national television in
the New Hampshire primary debates when
he murdered Marco Rubio then turned the
gun on himself politically speaking
leaving the pathway open to president
Trump remember Marco Rubio is gaining a
lot of momentum after Iowa and then
chris Christie took out Rubio and then
proceeded to hand over New Hampshire to
Trump well Christie is very angry now
he's very angry with the Trump
administration because he never got a
job in the Trump administration not even
getting those burgers for the Clemson
Tigers the other day during the campaign
chris Christie was the designated fast
food run guy but Chris Christie couldn't
even get that job apparently he was
briefly considered for chief of staff a
few weeks ago and then he was blocked in
that effort by other folks in trumps
immediate orbit and he can tell who was
trying to block him from who Chris
Christie is angry at so according to
Axios former New Jersey Governor Chris
Christie settled scores in let me finish
a memoir out January 29th from who shed
writing the president from trust people
he shouldn't including some of the
people who are closest to him first of
all that's a terrible name for a memoir
let me finish I mean honest to goodness
that's that's an awful name from Mr it
sounds like like a sports memoir
actually it sounds like a guy on sports
talk radio
it's like Stephen a Smith's let me
finish but instead it's Chris Christie
and let me finish in a second I'm gonna
explain what exactly is in this book
that's got the media so I guess so the
so Christie asserts that Trump has quote
a revolving door of deeply flawed
individuals amateurs grifters weaklings
convicted a nun convicted felons who are
hustled into jobs that were never suited
for sometimes seemingly without so much
as a background check via Google or
Wikipedia now I think there's some truth
to this in the early stages of the Trump
White House there are a lot of grifters
in the Trump White House very early on
because Trump had surrounded himself
with a lot of people who would work with
him a lot of the more mainstream kind of
Republicans would not work with him
during the campaign or early on in his
administration and as his administration
has progressed the administration has
actually gotten better and not worse so
Rex Tillerson has been replaced with
Mike Pompeo
good move you've seen that that Steve
Bannon was tossed out good move the
president's made
of good personnel moves in while he's
been there and he's upgraded in a bunch
of different ways that's really good
chris Christie those men that he wasn't
included in Trump White House 1.0 or
Trump White House 2.0 instead he just
thinks that he should have been
appointed VP right do you remember he
was considered for you have to feel a
little bad for Chris Christie right he
was considered for V for VP and then
rejected then he was considered for
Attorney General and rejected then he
was considered for chief of staff and
rejected so he couldn't even make water
boy at this White House here's what
Christie writes he says I did everything
I could to make sure my friend Donald
reached the White House fully prepared
to serve but a handful of selfish
individuals sidetracked our very best
efforts this is the point at which a
mirror slowly raises in front of Chris
Christie to awaken him to the fact that
he may have been one of these selfish
individuals in from sorbets said they
set loose toxic forces that have made
Trump's presidency far less effective
than it would otherwise have been
if this tragedy is ever going to be
reversed it is vital that everyone know
exactly how it occurred once Steve Benin
started unburdening himself in his Trump
Tower office he couldn't seem to stop
the kids been taking an axe to your head
with the boss ever since I got here he
blurted out it's been constant he never
stops ancient bitterness I guess this is
this is Christie whining about Jared
Kushner the president's son-in-law who's
been very effective and also very very
loud in terms of policy inside the White
House and Bannen speak the kid is only
one person not Donald jr. not younger
son Eric not a Vaughn Carter Tiffany the
kid is Jared Kushner the husband of
Ivanka Trump and the son of the real
estate developer Charles Kushner a man I
once sent to prison and Christie then
says he doesn't understand trump's
endgame and and he goes after trump
personally I do love that all these
people who really really wish that they
were involved with the Trump
administration write these books about
how terrible everyone in the Trump
administration isn't what they say is
he's just surrounded by bad people Trump
himself has never made a bad decision
it's just that he surrounds it by bad
people now listen President Trump is his
own man I think it is fair to say that
anybody who knows President Trump
anybody who knows the people who talked
to President Trump this this guy has a
mind of his own if you could control
President Trump do you think his
advisers would be letting him tweet
asinine things every five seconds do you
truly think that his advisers would be
in favor of him going on Twitter and
then just unleash
a Syrian withdrawal do you think that
his advisers would be super happy with
him going on Twitter and then ripping
into Elizabeth Warren by mentioning
Wounded Knee and probably not Trump does
what he wants to do and yet there is
this mythos that's been built up around
Trump by people who want to kiss his
butt that says every mistake that you've
made it's because of bad advice it's
because the people around you have badly
advised you well you know one of those
people was during the campaign chris
christie who was there virtually the
whole time we all remember the videos of
chris christie looking like a wounded
dog as President Trump spoke and
Christie's off on the side looking like
deep down inside his soul he wants to
crawl into a hole cover himself up and
die so Christie going after other
members of the Trump administration now
that he's no longer there and now that
he's not been involved is pretty
scurrilous but I would expect nothing
less from chris Christie who is one of
the most egregiously egotistical
politicians in the history of Republican
politics so media of course are very
excited over all of this and they hope
that this will be the kill shot they're
kind of simply hoping that something
will be the kill shot with regard to the
Trump presidency the truth is the only
thing that's gonna end the Trump
presidency if anything does is going to
be him being defeated in 2020 and we'll
talk about the 2020 candidates in in
just a minute
first I want to talk a little bit about
the the an ad that was put out by
Harry's razor so we talked about
Gillette a couple of days ago Gillette
put out an ad about masculinity about
how masculinity was really bad right
toxic masculinity and the ad featured a
bunch of guys grilling while they
watched two kids beat the snot out of
each other and did nothing and then the
and then the Gillette ad said well this
is what men have been doing basically
since time immemorial it's time for men
to change it's time for men to change
well now in their race to the bottom in
the race to the woke bottom now we've
got Harry's razor that has jumped into
the fray
yesterday they tweeted because it was
international men's day and here's what
they tweeted today is international
men's day believe it or not that's a
thing now more than ever being a man to
man's introspection humility and
optimism to get to a better tomorrow we
need to take a look at today and if the
misguided stereotypes that got us here
in the first place and then they put up
a bunch of
and cross them out because these phrases
are apparently very bad what are these
phrases these are phrases like boys will
be boys because we can't say that or man
up
if you say man up that's bad because if
you say man up you're implying that
somebody should be a man and you know
make sacrifices take responsibility
stop widening in the words of Arnold
Schwarzenegger hey they say it's time
for a new definition of masculinity yeah
and they say that if you say grow up
here to somebody that this is really bad
if you say that being a man has anything
to do with you know not being a wimp and
not being a loser and taking
responsibility for your own life that's
really bad so they say it's time for a
new definition of masculinity now I
don't know why all these razor companies
have suddenly decided to cut themselves
off at the knees with their entire base
right which are men as it turns out but
it has something to do with the draw of
social media to focus on the left one of
the most amusing things about folks on
the online left is that the same folks
who despise capitalism think capitalism
is terrible hate major corporations they
will happily retweet Harry's razor and
Gillette and Nike look they're so woke
now meanwhile all those companies are
making Bank off the leftists or suddenly
Pro these corporations so the
corporation's have a monetary interest
in doing all of this I saw statistic
this morning that Gillette was mentioned
on Twitter 1.5 million times this week
the previous week ten thousand times so
this campaign is working for them same
thing with Harry's razor but it does
speak to what the left actually thinks
of masculinity which is that masculinity
is really really really bad and left
hatred for masculinity crosses all
boundaries in a second I want to get to
CNN attacking president Trump for use it
for making a gender joke it's really
cool oh my god how could he how could he
we'll talk about that in just one second
first I have a question for you are you
more Native American than Elizabeth
Warren so we know a few things about
Elizabeth Warren she likes to drink beer
she's glad her husband is at home when
she's making an ad for the presidency
and she is 1/1000 24th maybe Native
American you might be more Native
American than Elizabeth Warren
how would you that find that out you go
to 23andme 23andme allows you to go
beyond ancestry and access more
personalized insights based on your DNA
so I've taken the 23andme test what it
found is that true to form I'm 100
percent Ashkenazi Jewish and people get
on Mike
when I say that I'm a hundred percent
Ashkenazi Jewish that's not a point of
superiority it doesn't matter in the
grand scheme of things but it's kind of
fun to know that my ancestry is really
really really Jewish what's your
ancestry like I also found out traits
like apparently I have the body mass of
a muscle like a bodybuilder I mean I
knew that too because underneath this
coat why is the body of a Greek god no
one knows that except my wife but let me
tell you it's it's stunning but I no
know that because of 23andme and I have
objective proof of it I think of your
lactose intolerance report a caffeine
consumption report that tells you how
much caffeine you tend to consume a
genetic weight report so you can
discover if your genes predispose you to
way more or less than average by your
23andme health and ancestry kit today at
23andme calm / appear oh that's the
number two three and me.com slash
Shapiro again 23andme calm slash apparel
go check it out two three and me comm
23andme dot-com slash Shapiro go check
it out right now it's a lot of fun
you're gonna want to do it okay so
meanwhile the attack on masculinity
continues apace attack on masculinity
and humor apparently if you believe that
there are men and there are women and
these are two different things
then this is very very bad and if you
make a joke about women in any way and
this is particularly terrible so here's
Erin Burnett Erin Burnett yesterday on
CNN the CNN panel was very upset with
President Trump why because President
Trump hosted the Clemson football team
and they joked that Melania could make
some salads maybe oh no we must never
suggest that Melania makes salads no we
can't do that to the same media who hate
Melania Trump so much that they've never
put her on the cover of a single fashion
magazine I can think of while they're
falling over themselves to put Michelle
Obama on fashion magazines and just on
an objective level like Melania Trump
was a model she was like an actual model
and they won't put her on fashion
magazines now they're saying it is
beneath Melania Trump to make a salad
beneath her
hey here's Erin Burnett being very very
deeply offended at Trump joking that his
wife might make a salad by the way you
know what my wife does when people come
over she make salads for people like
really it's a thing that she does and
she's a doctor so that's not me ripping
I'm the ability of women to operate in
the workplace here's Erin Burnett being
a dummy is one of those things where
sometimes what people say when they're
being funny is exposes exactly who they
are and what they
not that there was any question but this
is pretty clear how in the world do not
perceive that as sexist to say some
just wife's gonna go make salads for the
bunch of football players what does she
like the cook I'm not over reading it he
made a joke that was sexist about women
I guess what I guess maybe what we're
disagreeing with is whether it's funny
and whether humor is is something that's
serious whether humor is something
that's serious no as it turns out the
definition of humor is that it's not
serious because it's funny I like how
we're now rewriting all it so basically
according to the left
humor comedy is supposed to be serious
this is again why Hannah Gadsby is
renowned on the left for being a deeply
unfunny human being because she is woke
being woke is the new funny so she's
really funny Samantha B for some odd
reason is the new funny she never has to
make you laugh just to make you think
making you think is the new funny and
also if you say something that is a joke
and we are going to take it similarly
seriously because it reveals your
inherent biases so if President Trump
makes a joke about Melania Trump making
a salad well obviously he hates women
clearly clearly and first of all if you
want evidence the president from Inc
great with the ladies I got a whole long
list for you I got like a big long list
of comments that President Trump has
made about women in the past that are
really quite terrible if the one you
pick on is that he made a joke about his
own wife making salads you may have from
derangement syndrome pretty amazing
stuff speaking of a derangement syndrome
so the left has decided now that Steve
King is the most important person in
America that's because Steve King last
week said something racist Jesus did a
New York Times interview and in The
Times interview he suggested that the
phrases white nationalism and white
supremacy were unobjectionable or should
be unobjectionable now Kings defense to
this is he says that the New York Times
took him out of context and what he
actually was talking about is that the
left conflates and uses all of these
phrases routinely to slander kind of
normal ideas like Western civilization
whatever it is Steve King has walked
that line many many times and I have
given him the benefit of the doubt in
cases past and I think now in retrospect
unjustifiably so at a certain point you
can't give somebody the benefit of the
doubt anymore well because so here's
what happens Steve King says something
that is overtly bad now he said
something overtly bad was caught on tape
by the week
standard last year and many people on
the right including me condemned him for
that at the time okay so when that
happened then there wasn't that much
press about it there wasn't a huge
amount of press about it now the right
has decided to disown Steve King because
he said something so egregious that
there's just no way to walk back from it
and it's too it's it's it's incredibly
obvious it's too obvious for him to
wiggle out of as he may have in the past
so what is the left to the right
condemns Steve King and excises him
right they remove all his committee
assignments he's being primaried the
NRCC declared months ago they wouldn't
support him in his in his general
election effort even he almost lost to a
Democrat in a heavy red district in Iowa
so the Republicans have been working to
get rid of Steve King for a while here
just like they got rid of Roy Moore just
like they worked to get rid of a bunch
of Republicans in the past in the in the
John Birch Society in times past just
like they work to kind of fringe out Pat
Buchanan his oak the Republican Party
has tried to do this before but every
time the Republican Party tries to do
the right thing with somebody like Steve
King they immediately get whomped on the
head by the left who said well why
didn't you do this before what took you
so long you know the fact that you even
want to get rid of Steve King is
demonstrative of the fact you are racist
so the way this works is if you don't
get rid of Steve King you're a racist if
you do get rid of Steve King you are
also a racist because you didn't get rid
of Steve King before instead of well I'm
glad that you finally came around on
Steve King it's well I'm glad you
finally came came around on Steve King
but not really I'm not really that glad
you came around on Steve King in fact
you're an idiot for having apologized or
for having come around on Steve King in
the first place you wonder why so many
Republicans so many people on the right
I'm willing to double down in defense of
people who should not be defended it's
because if you actually come out and
condemn bad behavior on your own side
you don't get credit for it from the
left instead the left suggests that you
are part of a broader racist movement
and it's that that has allowed people on
the right and give an impetus to people
on the right to give benefit of the
doubt in cases where maybe they
shouldn't have given benefit of the
doubt if you call everything racist
people on the right are immediately
going to say well you've called like
Utley you have Mitt Romney a racist so
why would I take you seriously when you
call this other person a racist
maybe you're just deliberately
misinterpreting them - you're acting in
bad faith the left refuses to
acknowledge that it has ever mislabeled
anyone
folks on the left believe that every
time they label something racist it is
racist and there is no problem of over
broadly applying the label racist
because everything is racist in their
view now if everything is racist then
that's going to lead to a reactionary
response that goes overboard in which
people assume that nothing is racist
which of course is also not true but
watch the reaction of folks on the left
to the right
condemning Steve King like literally
every major Republican I've spoken to or
who has commented publicly is condemned
and Steve King he's his base of support
has been completely undercut and yet
Bill Maher Bill Maher who's used the
n-word on his own show I should mention
Bill Maher goes on MSNBC and talking to
Chris Matthews and he suggests that
Republicans are so racist that we're
supposed to cheer them for denouncing
white supremacy no you're supposed to
actually treat it honestly when people
do the right thing but we can't do that
we have to rip people when they do the
right thing where the bar is Chris that
we're cheering the Republicans because
they say we don't believe in white
supremacy this is how far down we've
gone this is where they draw the line
I'm glad they drew the line somewhere
because I'm beginning to wonder if they
would ever draw a line but but again the
question we always have to ask is what
will the Republicans put up with that's
what it comes down to okay why do we
always ask that question after the right
doesn't put up with something again the
right sacrificed a Senate seat in
Alabama do not put up with Roy Moore the
right has sacrificed that I mean the
right basically sacrificed a Senate seat
in Virginia because Cory steward was
vaguely on that racist fringe right he
had he had neo Confederates in his
campaign and such so the right has
sacrificed to Senate seats basically to
the proposition that there are certain
people who should not be part of the
Republican caucus but for the left that
means that the right is racist and bad
because again the left conflates
everything that is conservatism with
racism so what they do is they say well
obviously you guys were motivated by
racism your desire for the wall is
coming from the same place as Steve
King's desire for a wall even if you
don't like Steve King even if you think
that his comments are ridiculous let me
get some more of this in just one second
but first we need to talk about how
you're gonna maintain your energy level
today
to get started everyday and then you
have bursts of productivity and then you
crash again in the mid-afternoon and you
kind of limp across that 5:00 p.m.
finish line what if you could avoid
drinking multiple cups of coffee or cans
of soda or energy drinks to survive that
day well a bunch of physicians gathered
and they formed a brick house nutrition
they developed an advanced formula to
stimulate more than just your heart also
your brain and your cells called dawn to
dusk dawn to dusk provides clean energy
focus improved mood for up to 10 hours
no jitters no afternoon crash no
calories no sugar folks around the
office have been using it let me tell
you they are much more productive with
dawn to dusk there's no need to be
anxious when your coffee mug is empty
while others leave the office for that
overpriced refill you're still getting
things done give it a try
Brickhouse been calm so you can get a
bottle of this formula Brickhouse been
calm get a bottle try it out when you
use promo code Ben you get 15% off your
first order again 15% off your first
order give it a try you really don't
have anything to lose brick house been
calm again that's brick house been calm
you can be more productive you can have
more energy
give it a try give it a spin brick house
been calm she can get a bottle of this
groundbreaking formula and use that
promo club and get 15% off your first
order go check it out right now brick
house been calm again brick house been
calm okay well I'm gonna get to the
response of Megan McCain yesterday to
all the allegations that the Republicans
are widely racist in the aftermath of
them excising someone who said a racist
thing we'll get to that in just one
second first you're gonna have to go and
subscribe at daily wire calm when you do
you get the rest of this show live you
get the rest of the Andrew Clavin show
you live you get the rest of the mount
Walsh alive and today on the Michael
motional live - I mean I almost forgot
about Michael because why would I
remember him but today and every day
when you subscribe you get two
additional hours of me later today I'm
I'm here slaving away for you people and
my goodness the least you could do is
join up and become a subscriber when you
do and you get the annual subscription
you also get this the very greatest and
beverage vessels look at this the
leftist here's hot or cold tumblr view
this magnificent enjoy it feast your
eyes upon it and then get it yourself
with the annual subscription we have all
sorts of goodies for you when you
subscribe also you should subscribe at
YouTube or iTunes because we have a
Sunday special that you won't get if
you're not a subscriber so go check it
out today's this week's Sunday special
is Lieutenant Colonel
Alan West American hero here is
Lieutenant Colonel West hey greetings
everyone Lieutenant Colonel retired Alan
West form
member of Congress I'm here with Ben
Shapiro on the Ben Shapiro show Sunday
special
please join us here at the Daily wire
where we talk about how we can really
get America back in shape and we can
restore this constitutional republic
great young man he lowered his standards
so I could be here but check him out
okay so the well we'll get to more of
our show in just one second first go
subscribe right now again daily we're
calm 99 bucks a year we are the largest
fastest-growing conservative podcast in
the nation
[Music]
all righty so Jim Costin who I've talked
up her work before she has a piece over
at voxcom that's pretty interesting cuz
why Republicans took so long to call out
Steve Kings racism and her basic thesis
is that Republicans ignored it because
they don't take racism all that
seriously I mean that really is hurt her
essential thesis she says that the right
has defined racism down to if you say
something clearly white supremacist then
we exercise you anything else we won't
but that obviously is untrue because
there are a bunch of people on the right
who have been excised for saying things
that are borderline before folks like me
were very critical of President Trump in
the aftermath of Charlottesville for
example right Trump got reamed by a lot
of folks on the right for his comments
in the aftermath of Charlottesville but
that's not good enough according to the
left the right just doesn't get racism
because racism is far broader than just
people being white supremacist Jane Jane
basically she calls Peter Beinart who is
an awful awful columnist who wrote in
2017 conservatives feel their cultural
vulnerability acutely in 2011
researchers at Tufts University observed
that conservatives consume more outrage
based political radio and television
than liberals do one reason they
suggested in a follow-up paper is that
conservatives are more fearful than
liberals of discussing politics with
people with whom they disagree because
they dread being called a bigot liberals
expressed no comparable fear as a result
they felt less need to take refuge and
the safe political environs provided by
outrage based programming well the
reason that the right fears being called
the bigot is because the left will call
you a bigot for legitimately anything
Mitt Romney was called the bigot John
McCain was called the bigot rick perry
was called the bigot george w bush was
called the bigot named a republican who
has not been called the bigot one can
you name a republican who has not been
called a racist or bigoted now folks on
the lefthand sir by saying that's
because all republicans are racists and
bigots and that's what drives the right
to not take seriously certain
allegations from the left of bigotry and
that's why and I've said this before
that's what's led me in the past to
grant the benefit of the doubt to people
like Steve King right I said I went back
and I updated an article that I wrote in
2017 in which he said something that
could be interpreted one of two ways I
talked about this on the show last week
he said something about we can't restore
our civilization with somebody else's
babies and I said that this could be
interpreted a couple of different ways
one is the racist way that black and
brown babies can't become members of
Western civilization and the
other way is suggesting that people who
are raised in a different culture are
going to have a bad impact on our
civilization if that culture runs
counter to the culture of our
civilization and King went on TV and
he's sort of clarified it in the second
way and I said well you need to grants
him the benefit of the doubt well maybe
I shouldn't have granted him the benefit
of the doubt but the idea is that
everything King has been saying for 15
years is inherently racist and what the
left does and this is how they get
themselves in trouble that's what drives
a reactionary response from the right is
they take a bunch of comments that King
said that are borderline and dicey and
bad and then they lump them together
with a bunch of normal conservative
commentary and say well obviously all of
these comments are racist so for example
when he ripped in to multiculturalism a
while back this was considered racist by
the New York Times it was not racist
that statement was not racist but when
he said stuff about how there were a
bunch of people who were crossing the
border with calves like cantaloupes that
was a lot closer to racism and maybe
outright racist according to the left if
you make any such distinction then you
are not taking racism seriously enough
and this of course is just a lie I think
there can be honest disagreement about
whether a comment is racist or not and
maybe it's easy to err on the side of
giving the benefit of the doubt to
people you don't give the benefit of the
doubt er you shouldn't but on the left
they give no benefit of the doubt to
anyone on the right but complete benefit
of it out to everyone on the left and so
for example you get Chuck Todd right so
Chuck Todd of NBC he says you know
Republicans are happy to condemn Steve
King's racism but they won't condemn
president Trump's racism I'm wondering
what world he's living in honestly
would it be the Republicans feel that
they can be tougher on racism on Steve
King after the midterm wiped out in the
suburbs could it be that they feel that
they can't criticize a president he's
very popular among their own primary
voters could it be the fear president
Trump would punish them by supporting a
primary challenger well you know the
answers to all of those questions yes
yes and yes
okay or maybe it is that a lot of
Republicans did criticize Trump in the
aftermath of Charlottesville maybe it is
that a lot of Republicans were very
critical of Trump during the 2016 race
maybe it is that you can't get rid of
Trump the same way that you can get rid
of Steve King right by primary a min a
congressional race and maybe it is that
Trump didn't actually come out and just
say white nationalism the white
supremacy okay right I mean come on but
according to Chuck Todd it's it's it
always comes down to the same thing so
Megan McCain I think rightly went after
folks on the view because folks on the
view began conflating support for a
border wall with Steve King like racism
and here is Megan McCain aptly taking
down this argument 42 percent of this
country that isn't worth the wall are
they all racist oh that's a good
question there are a lot of people that
support that wall and I think when you
blanket I think this is the problem with
identity politics in the country which
is something we sort of touched on
yesterday is when you broad-stroke
everyone all black people think one
thing always better people think one
thing are publicans think one thing
that's how we got ourselves into this
mess do you think 42% of Americans are
racist I just said I don't know well you
did just call 42% of the country there
was an implication that they could be
racist okay and and the folks on the
left is a very convenient argument for
them is that if you support a particular
policy this means that you are
inherently racist and people unless and
where's the evidence that you're not
racist you know there's an interesting
question of burden of proof here and
burden of proof in the law is the
question of whether you're accused of a
crime is the burden of proof on the
police to prove that you committed the
crime or is the burden on you to prove
that you are innocent according to the
left we can automatically assume you're
you are you're guilty of the crime of
racism based on your political positions
and then it is up to you to prove that
you are not in fact a racist and every
attempt to prove you're not a racist
proves more than you're a racist because
you didn't do something else the left
wanted you to do okay so if you are for
a wall we can assume you're a racist and
then if say well I'm not a racist they
say proven you say well you know like
Steve Kings had this thing the other day
and I condemned that so why don't you
condemn every other comments that Steve
King ever made hmm hmm
say well maybe you're being
intellectually dishonest and what you
actually want to do is just apply the
racist label as broadly as possible
because it is politically beneficial and
allows you to pat yourself on the back
meanwhile being fine with racism in your
own ranks the Democratic Party obviously
okay with with anti-semitism in their
own ranks
the DNC covered its but yesterday by
disassociating from the women's March
after it became completely obvious from
Tameka Mallory and others they would not
disassociate from Louis Farrakhan never
mind the fact that 21 different members
of the Democratic caucus have taken
pictures and and hung out with Louis
Farrakhan none of whom have ever
condemned Louis Farrakhan in any way and
then and you have folks in the
democratic caucus like Rashida to Labe
know who is a fresh-faced because she's
a Muslim Congress person now there you
can get Muslim Congress person not be an
anti-semite obviously Rashida too late
however is an anti-semite their religion
to the side she suggests that we're anti
her because she's Muslim not because
she's an anti-semite so she tweeted out
today right-wing media targeting me
again rather than focusing on the
president's reckless government shutdown
yes I am a Muslim and I'm Palestinian
get over it focus on the human impact of
this disaster hashtag and the shutdown
turns out I can focus on both the
shutdown and the fact that your radical
anti-semite the entire Democratic caucus
is cheering on I can do both those
things now I can ask the same questions
about Democratic willingness to accept
anti-semitism that the left asks about
right-wing willingness to accept racism
the difference is that nobody in the
Democratic Party has condemned Rashid
it's labeled once a time a time the
Democratic Party gets mild credit for
having withdrawn from the women's March
but they don't get full credit simply
because they still have members in their
caucus who are saying things like we're
sheet of too late and they don't care
they don't care so what am I supposed to
take away from that and it's not like
this is this is a big secret something
so let's be real about this people do
what's politically convenient there is
some of this on both sides people are
willing to overlook bad stuff on their
own side they would not be willing to
overlook on somebody else's side and we
all have to fight that instinct but to
pretend that that instinct is inevitably
tied to some deep-rooted discriminatory
belief system is ridiculous again I
think that you can make a better case
that the Democratic Party has embraced
anti-semitism considering that they
Jerusalem in the DNC in 2012 considering
the fact that they on mass voted against
a proposition to condemn BDS considering
that they have treated anti-semites in
their caucus with warmth without apology
for years then you can make the case
that the entire Republican Party is
racist because they just got rid of
Steve Kagan I think that's a bigger it's
a much bigger stretch okay meanwhile in
other news Kirsten Gillibrand of New
York has announced she is running for
president because we need 1,000
candidates who are all the same so
Kirsten Gillibrand is gonna run for
president on the exact same platform as
bethe O'Rourke or Kamala Harris or any
other of the the Democratic candidates
but she's running for president on a
really unique platform she's a woman
unlike 50% of the population she in fact
is a woman she announced that she was
running for president and was given time
to do so by Stephen Colbert who has
become basically just a bullhorn for
Democratic presidential politics here is
the unchartered malleable Kirsten
Gillibrand remember when she first ran
for Congress she ran as a quasi pro-life
pro-gun Democrat now she's a radical
left Democrat she's basically you know
they do this routine with Jeff Bridges
and all of his movies now where the kind
of age reverse him like they did in Tron
I mean they sort of age reverse these
actors they did it with Nicole Kidman in
Aquaman where they make them look
younger so basically Kristin told
Brennan is just Hillary Clinton age
reversed
so here's Kirsten Gillibrand on Stephen
Colbert announcing she's running for
president I'm just curious do you have
anything you would like to announce yes
and what would that be madam I'm filing
an exploratory committee president the
United States
I like the half-hearted cheers from the
people in the studio they like yeah all
right Emily Colbert can't even get his
audience up for it like Colbert is
desperately trying to get his audience
excited about Kirsten Gillibrand and
Kirsten Gillibrand families out in the
audience come yeah
well okay I guess so flashback to like a
minute ago when Kirsten Gillibrand said
that she would serve her full term in
the Senate without running for president
yeah she was lying just like she has
about every other policy position she's
ever taken just want to make this quick
you were saying you will not get out of
the race that you a lot run for
president you will serve your six years
I will serve my 60 year term okay well
she's right she will serve her six year
term because she's not getting nominated
so she will actually serve her six year
term but she was lying then because this
is what politicians do on a regular
basis and it's really stupid and
irritating what is her platform gonna be
her platform is gonna be I'm a woman mm
congratulations lady here she is this is
the moment you will remember when women
stood strong and stood firm okay by the
way that is Kristin gentle brand
speaking at the Women's March last year
the DNC has now disassociated from the
women's march over their association
with anti-semitism so things are going
great for Kristin Gillibrand right out
of the gate it is amazing that in the
Democratic Party the only thing in the
end that really matters well there there
two factors that really matter one is
media coverage and the other is how many
intersectional check boxes yet right
that that really is it so common law
Harris will do much better than kirsten
gillibrand
because she's not just a woman she's a
black woman which means even more
victimized in American society even
though by the way the evidence does not
show that if the evidence doesn't show
that black women based on when you
remove all other factors are deeply
victimized by American society in fact
black women growing up in high-income
households tend to out-earn white women
according to a recent study from
Stanford University and the Census
Bureau in any case Kamala Harris has
been given the patina of intersectional
advantage by the left so she has an
advantage over Kirsten Gillibrand also
it means that she gets better media
coverage the media coverage battle also
concerns people like baito or work or
Bob O'Rourke and and Bob o apparently is
going to get really great me
coverage as well Bernie Sanders is
pretty much done Elizabeth Warren
doesn't have the same pizzazz Kamala
Harris and she's triangle for that
Bernie Sanders crowd and she might get
some of them but she'll split that vote
right now if you had to handicap the
Democratic race I would say that the
chances of a of a comely Harris beta
overall ticket are really good I'd say
that's probably the the most likely
ticket at this point not sure whether
it's O'Rourke or whether it's Harris on
the top of that ticket but Harris
obviously gonna be given a big boost by
the folks on the Left who are super not
racist but also will tell you that
Kamala Harris has qualified for
president specifically because of her
race but they're super not they don't
think in terms of race only you think in
terms of race because you think it's bad
when someone uses the term white
supremacist or white nationalist without
condemning it okay time for it some
things I like and then some things that
I hate so things I like today so after
we saw into the spider-verse my wife and
I rented spider-man homecoming and it's
perfectly serviceable it's a charming
movie you know it's not any great shakes
but I will say that the the new you know
the guy who plays spider-man now is much
better than Tobey Maguire now so if I I
mean let's be real about this it's hard
to be worse than Tony Blair was in the
in the old spider-man series and we
relaunched spider-man you know every
couple of years here at this point but
the movie is fun it really portrays
Peter Parker the way that he is in the
comics is like an actual teenager as
opposed to Tobey Maguire who is 51 who
is playing spider-man so then the movie
is is worth the watch it's pretty fun go
check it out here's a little bit of a
preview of spider-man homecoming I also
play it because there's also a new
trailer for the next spider-man movie
I'll discuss that in just one second
I can keep that suit yeah
doesn't fit me what is the next retreat
what next mission
we'll call you all right the movie is
very okay it's mostly okay because
Robert Downey jr. is in it and it's kind
of a you know it's a typical Marvel
movie in the sense that it's enjoyable
cotton candy
now there's a new preview out for the
new spider-man movie which just shows
you that you are all suckers okay you
remember I got very angry at Avengers
infinity war if you go back on the
program
view the old episodes what you'll see is
that people were very mad at me because
I was mad at Avengers infinity war why
because people were like crying at the
end of the vengers infinity war and like
waited dumb what do you idiots yeah of
course at the end of Avengers infinity
war when Thanos snaps his fingers and
half the population disappears and
Robert Downey jr. iron man watches as
spider-man disappears I was like yeah
yeah sure you're right they're gonna
kill off these billion-dollar characters
just to finish the infinity war movie so
I'm not gonna here's the deal I'm not
gonna cry over spider-man being killed
at the end of Avengers infinity war or
Black Panther which literally made a
billion dollars at the box office I
don't think they actually killed Black
Panther in fact I remember watching the
ending sequence and Avengers infinity
war and they killed off some of the
fringe characters I'm like wow that's
kind of that's kind of interesting and
then they killed off Black Panther I was
like nope nope
you guys just spend a bunch of money on
that movie it just made a boatload of
money it's gonna win it's gonna win
awards for intersectional reasons and
you're gonna kill off that character
uh-huh uh-huh and then they cut off
spider-man I was like nope so now the
new spider-man movie is coming out and
spider-man is shockingly alive in that
movie and people like oh so you mean
that he doesn't die in Avengers infinity
war right adults so if he cried when it
was obvious that these characters were
not dying I would say that your
suspension of disbelief has gone too far
now I know I'm gonna get a bunch of
flack for saying this because hey
there's a fictional movie and you've
made fun of fictional movies before
right but you have to have enough
respect for the audience that there has
to be at least some logical consistency
within the universe that you've created
if every if every fictional movie ended
with a giant Godzilla foot stomping all
the characters out of existence I think
it'd be fair to criticize the movie for
failing to move within the universe and
hit created so you can't expect me to be
a motion
within the Avengers universe when you're
coming off characters who I know are not
dead in the slightest now to be fair to
cry at the next Avengers movie when they
kill off in my prediction Captain
America Iron Man and Thor all three of
whom will be taken out because they're
too expensive for Marvel which is the
real reason they'll be taken out and you
know then I guess it's no fair it's okay
to get emotional but if you got
emotional over spider-man disappearing
then you're just stupid
sorry it's sorry break it to you okay
time for a thing that I hate so a couple
of things that I hate today people are
very angry at Karen Penn so Karen pence
is the wife of the vice president and
she has taken a job according to media
eye with a private school that
discriminates against gay people and
members of the LGBT community at large
what exactly is this terrible horrible
school she's taken a gigas in our
teacher for Emmanuel Christian school in
Northern Virginia the school's
application form requires teachers and
staff to uphold traditional Christian
norms and values including against a
pledge against sexual immorality which
includes homosexual conduct this means
she's very very bad she's teaching at a
Christian school that upholds you know
like Christian principles terrible
terrible woman
how dare she teach at a religious school
if you are one of these intolerant
jackasses who thinks that it's very bad
for a Christian to teach at a Christian
school because the Christian school
upholds Christian principles get out
more I deal with some people who don't
necessarily agree with your secular
humanist worldview deal with some folks
who may in fact be religious and who
treat you well in normal life and
believe that certain things are sins
that you don't believe are sins
just get over it you want to live in a
diverse society you may it you might
have to start by recognizing that our
diverse society has people of religious
belief inside of it the Washington Post
is very angry at this however they say
that the the form includes a section
that says moral misconduct which
violates the bona fide occupational
qualifications for employees includes
but is not limited to such behaviors as
the following heterosexual activity
outside of marriage and I noticed that
the media ID story is not very upset
about this one that the school condemns
heterosexual activity outside of
marriage they're not upset about that
one because they think that it's not
necessarily that immoral to tell
straight people not to have sex outside
of marriage but I think it's SuperDuper
terrible to say that if you engage in
homosexual activity then that is a sin
in the Christian
view although all of these are sins in
the Christian view okay
premarital sex cohabitation extramarital
sex homosexual or lesbian sexual
activity polygamy transgender identity
any other violation of the unique rules
of male and female sexual harassment
youths are viewing of pornographic
materials or website
so basically schools can have social
standards so long as those social
standards are approved by the left and
if those social standards are not
approved by the left you cannot
associate with that school or with that
synagogue or with that Church you know
my response to this if you're gonna try
and tell me where I can send my kids to
school because you think you know better
for my kids than I do or because you
think that your secular worldview is
somehow morally better innately than my
religious worldview you can go to hell
I'm really not interested in your
opinion on this and I don't think Karen
Pence is either and I think she has
every right to tell these people to take
a long walk off a short pier and other
things that I hate today so beta
O'Rourke is another one of these 2020
hotshot frontrunners he has an interview
that demonstrates that the dude is just
an empty vessel I mean he's just an
empty vessel didn't interview with the
Washington Post and somebody suggested
to me yesterday and I tweeted it out
that beta O'Rourke is basically poochy
from The Simpsons that just goes around
on a skateboard he's like hey guys
awesome and then everybody's enemies
like yeah that's bait over work and you
can tell from this interview in The
Washington Post it's pretty amazing the
interview is basically better or work
just not answering questions so for
example they asked him what should be
done to address visa overstays he says I
don't know pausing in a lengthy
interview and then they asked him about
the visa systems and harmonizing them
with Mexico he says that's an answer but
that's something that we should be
debating and then they asked him about
the wall and he says he says the genius
is we can mount non-violently resolve
our differences so I won't get to my
version of perfect or I working with you
we'll get to something better than what
we have today it's rare someone's ever
been able to impose their will
unilaterally in this country we don't
want that so we're like we just asked
about like whether you like wall or not
and we and asked about non-violence and
it's it like to every question to every
question he just answers I trust the
wisdom of the people the people will do
the right thing I just asked you if you
want to order a burger
okay I'm not asking you for like your
all thoughts on the wisdom of the people
which by the way you know what I'd love
to hear one day for a politician is a
politician say you know at some times
people are just dumb all right sometimes
the people make dumb decisions sometimes
then this kind of worship for popular
sovereignty is really ridiculous no I'm
a fan of popular sovereignty because as
Winston Churchill put it it's the best
system it's it's the worst system aside
from all the others we don't have a
better system but this kind of I trust
the people routine that you get from
both right and left the Peet the
American people always know best really
did the American people always know best
I don't think so I think there are many
cases in which the American people do
not know best which is why leadership is
important which is why sometimes you
have to propose unpopular ideas and then
try to teach people about those ideas
until they become popular the the
essence of being a good leader or good
politician is not necessarily bowing to
the whims of public pressure but
o'rourke is one slim read I mean that's
you'd bow before every political wind
available when asked about Syria he says
he'd like to see a debate a discussion a
national conversation when asked about a
green new deal
he says I'm glad the work has been done
to articulate the goal that's a perfect
point from which to start a conversation
how about like a position how about a
thing yeah think how about that that
would be good then we can know whether
you're whether you're proposing
something good or not but this is the
front one of the frontrunner for the
Democratic parties you've got Kamala
Harris who's it down the line
progressive we did a terrible job as
Attorney General in California she's a
front-runner yeah beta O'Rourke who
doesn't hold the position but rides a
skateboard guys and has long bangs that
he can flick back romantically in the
sunlight whoa hey and you've got Kirsten
Gillibrand
who's a shapeshifter it will take any
position that is necessary for her to
take so long as it also allows her to
say that she's doing it as a woman well
great great gang you brought here guys
now if any of these people win in 2020
we got a problem we got a problem now
that's not to suggest the president
Trump is perfect in any way but it does
show the threat of the left because my
goodness gracious that's some bad stuff
by the way Bader over finished his
interview interview by saying that we
may not be able to govern under the
Constitution he says we can't be maybe
we can't be managed by the same
principles that were set down 200
30-plus years ago that should be
frightening to anyone but I guess that
we don't get frightened by people saying
the one overthrow the Constitution
unless those people are
of the trumpian persuasion okay well we
will be back here tomorrow with much
much more plus later today if you're a
subscriber you get two additional hours
of me that's the thing you get every day
go subscribe right now what are you
waiting for
honestly I have so much more to say
about things but we've run out of time
so go check out more later today daily
where I comment subscribe I'll see you
there or we'll see you tomorrow
is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Adam sy events
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Joshua alvera production
assistant Nick Sheehan the Ben Shapiro
show is a daily wired production
copyright daily wire 20 19